as minority executive i think it's my
responsibility to let you know that gabe
is gross
happy birthday to cave oh get out
skeleton man
ta-da
okay it's two giant dogs with two giant
palm trees on a regular-sized island oh
i got one yeah yes okay i'm sorry but
i'm gonna have to shut this down
unless we can all agree to some ground
rules it's either that or i can fax this
to joe and let her decide how to proceed
gabe
tell us your stupid rules so we can
start the game number one and this
should be obvious no captions that
insult the company we work for irony is
such a critical one number two
no pop culture references
seriously well i think we can all agree
they tend to alienate those who don't
get the reference making them feel like
the other wrap it up gabe okay final
thing and this is a fun one instead of
writing the caption directly under the
picture
let's all try using sticky quips right
new from dunder mifflin saver sticker
clips are fun they are safe they are
handy
i like to use sticky clips as regular
post-it notes put them in a fun mood
not every day
go get them start quipping
pam i think i'm gonna send you an i am
oh okay
send me one too yeah yeah put me on that
cece
so these are your cheeses your hams your
sausages your herbs and your vegetables
here's what's been done start creating
sometimes it helps to think of a part of
the world and you can make okay okay
okay
gabe likes to entertain a lot
and he cooks in an oven
and all that jazz i just have a
different lifestyle
they have these bags of vegetables that
steam right inside their own bag
so i'll get a glass of sangria sit down
in front of tv a bag of vegetables
before you know it i'm ready for bed
okay you don't really toss the dough
try to destroy the old ways gabe i will
not let you
so what no one's even gonna try
guess not oh come on my rules could not
possibly have been that oppressive you
crushed our spirits gabe congrats
you're big man huh
takes a lot to destroy the creativity of
a whole group of people
hey
click the x i'm clicking in the box i am
clicking woman you've had a computer
phyllis it's too late
oh
and i am chat
very clever i'll just print that out
come on guys grow up
i don't want to be your babysitter
excuse me ms bennett may have a word
okay uh can it be in private don't worry
it's not about you
as minority executive i think it's my
responsibility to let you know that gabe
is gross
i don't think it's professional that he
was sleeping with a receptionist and
then when aaron dumped him so that she
could be with andy he became a total
crazy stalker psycho
gotta catch a plane
oh hey gabe i'm sorry we we didn't get
you a cake or anything we're gonna miss
you oh well i'm still the corporate
liaison to the branch you are not
leaving not giving me a hug
okay you know what you don't need to
make that sound i'm sorry you were just
a lot bonier than i thought you were
gonna be there were plenty of people who
love touching me i'm a terrific hugger
i've been with a bunch of girls where
that's basically all they want to do
i was thinking um
maybe while we read through this uh you
could give us awesome coffee my treat
it's a hundred dollar bill should cover
it i think
don't bring me any of that caramel soy
latte crab okay i want a decaf
frappuccino
val
actually val why don't you come with
i'll need the extra hands to carry the
mac yeah sure okay
caramel soy not a decaf crab got it
darn it bob i told you not to buy a
saber brand lifeboat
nice no not nice terrible
doesn't even include the fact that
they're dogs do the next one wake up
fred the power cord on your saber
printer shocked you into a coma and
you're dreaming you're a dog on a desert
island dreaming he's a dog on an island
excuse me excuse me how does the speaker
know what the guy in the coma is
dreaming well if you think it's so easy
gabe why don't you try it
um
you don't have to sniff my rear end
anymore bob i'm the only one here
that's tasteless gabe tasteless
tasteless more tasteless than this is
that a palm tree or do gabe get skinnier
either way let's pee on it
and gentlemen i think we have a winner
yes well done whose is it who wrote that
yeah
please it was easy once i decided i
wanted the dog to piss on gabe
and do you like being alone with me
right now
no this is horrifying no i don't like
being alone with me either
this is the first award i've ever won in
my entire life
people were right about the dundies
they are magical
but i don't feel it
and i think that's because i'm not with
the right person gabe
what
we should break up
what
i'm not attracted to you
i just i cringe when you talk
i have to be honest
right right pam
thank you for hearing me
okay well this is embarrassing um
obviously really angry at erin here
comes that quarter life crisis
everyone's talking about
all right i'm gonna go
look who i found yeah well i was very
hard to find let's go ahead and wash
your hands
is this the same
dough that you used for the pizza crust
yeah waste not right so these are pizza
dogs these aren't pigs in a blanket per
se michael knows everything there is to
know about snacks well
gabe was born in 1982. he was the
longest baby in the hospital he's the
longest baby in this room what's the
longest thing you've ever seen
for me it was the tail from a jet erin
you don't have to yeah you know what
eren you do after michael
you were making this harder than it has
to be that's what she said
two o'clock should probably be okay i
can either take your number or
i'm sorry this can't wait he's just
gonna call back erin i'm in love with
you
i don't believe in munch okay i don't
believe in horoscopes i don't believe in
christmas uh uh i sure as hell don't
believe in god
or maybe there's a god i don't i don't
know i mean it's just not a guy with a
long white beard
or it could be i mean it's possible that
that is exactly what what god is
but for for all of the disbelief
i believe in us
i believe in love
you have made me believe that for all of
the hokum out there
uh do we not have voicemail
dwight doesn't trust robots to give us
our messages
well
it just
it messes up my rhythm
i'm taking a break from dating
gabe was a great guy with so many
wonderful qualities but it was a
challenge being touched by him
can you stop talking because every word
out of your mouth is like the squawk of
an ugly pelican
i got a tattoo for you when our
warehouse workers make deliveries
they're going to be encouraged to offer
clients extra products and then they
will split those commissions with sales
wait so drivers are going to be able to
sell paper on their own that's correct
has anyone started calling you gabe wod
yet not here no gabe wad
maybe that's not the best one keep
reading uh it was maybe it wasn't oh
thank god i had a horrible nightmare
that i was stuck in america with gabe
[Music]
no that's not the one i was thinking of
keep going i know what it smells like
but i didn't roll in anything it's from
listening to all of gabe's bulls
isn't this the perfect romantic getaway
aaron sitting on a desert island in dog
costumes i'm gabe and
i'm a weirdo
mom hmm gabe's mom
wait tall woman looks like gabe
yeah i banged her yeah there we go
pam i have a loaded gun my desk at work
if i ever start acting like that weenie
gabe i want you to take that gun and i
want you to shoot me like a hundred
times on the groin until i'm dead okay
you have a gun in your desk
somewhere
i told him that there was this one cool
move where she powers down like a robot
okay okay but i i i'm so sorry that i
didn't tell you first well
don't let it happen again you think that
i would let this happen again
no way jose
i'm
q gabe
you